il ne pouvait rêver meilleur public pour
développer son programme autour de la
famille françois fillon a longuement été
applaudi lors de son meeting au palais
des congrès à versailles lundi soir dans
ce berceau de la manif pour tous dont
les militants avaient chahuté son
opposant bruno le maire il a quelques
mois l'ancien premier ministre a rappelé
qu'en cas de victoire il n'hésiterait
pas à réécrire la loi taubira pour
préserver la filiation l'incarnent les
valeurs que je défends et principalement
la famille ces mots candidat parce qu'il
a travaillé depuis trois ans avec
acharnement et en faisant remonter
toutes les informations économiques
importants qui seuls ces informations
économiques permettront à nouveau de
libérer l'entreprise de libérer toute
cette jeunesse plafonnant à 11%
d'intentions de vote lors du premier
tour de la primaire françois fillon
s'est montré combatif lors de son
discours mais aussi lors de la séance de
dédicace de son dernier ouvrage qu'il a
accordé un peu plus tôt dans la soirée
il sondage de m'assois dessus parce que
je pense qu'il va le pas grand chose
dans une primaire qui n'a aucune
référence à droite nous portent sur des
échantillons qui sont en général
extrêmement il modérée en tout cas
s'agissant de des gens qui veulent voter
et en plus la campagne pour les
primaires elle vient de commencer dans
le département françois fillon compte
parmi ses soutiens politiques la numéro
deux des républicains la sénatrice
sophie primas mais aussi plusieurs élus
locaux
selon plusieurs fois c'est çà çà çà çà
çà vérité je pense que c'est c'est
l'homme qu'il faut pour la france et le
tour de france se poursuit pour leur
candidat avant un premier débat télévisé
cette semaine premier tour de cette
primaire le 20 novembre